hello there I'm John Oliver host of
HBO's last week tonight and also banned
for life from the set of HBO's ballers
corn lead Wayne we can mend this feds
we're off this week but I'm here on the
Internet to do the most internet thing
imaginable and that is complain about
superhero movies every year the market
is flooded with movies about superheroes
just this year blockbusters included
movies ranging from mean Spider Man to
sad man vs. super sad man to the Insane
Clown Posse Takes Manhattan
now each of these movies have their
strengths and weaknesses which I will
not go into because I would like to feel
the touch of another human at least once
more before I die but I do think some
audience members are feeling a little
fatigued I've seen the same characters
over and over again and fear not because
I have a solution for fans who are
looking for something beyond the Marvel
and DC universes and I hope some movie
executives are watching this and taking
notes because ladies and gentlemen I
present to you next year's summer
blockbuster Johnny strong now now you
may notice that drawing is a little
amateurish and that is because Johnny
strong is a character that I created in
fifth grade by day he is mild-mannered
fifth-grader John Olivier no relation
but from the time school lets out until
dinner
he becomes the let's say
unconventionally handsome hero Johnny
strong Johnny strong is a kick-ass hero
with a bad attitude he's seen a boob and
he knows what the F word is he he
intrepidly battles villains such as Doc
bedtime a monster made of blankets who
can magically plunge the world into
total darkness and of course there's the
dreaded mrs. Thomas the clarinet teacher
no mrs. Thomas the clarinet is not the
electric guitar of the mouth you're a
charlatan and I don't want to play it I
don't want to play it Johnny doesn't
want to play it
the whole Johnny strong series is
chock-full of adventures that are
begging to be adapted to the silver
screen and where better to start than
with issue 1 which is called Night Moves
a title I did not realize was also the
name of a Bob Seger song now in Night
Moves an evil mutant monster has been
breaking into the Olivier household at
night probably to steal the awesome rock
collections of cool little boys and
Johnny strong can't sleep not because
he's scared he's very brave he just
can't fall asleep when there's injustice
afoot what's worse is that the grown-ups
are rendered incapable of seeing this
creature and are convinced that it is
just the cat but Johnny strong knows
better so Johnny developed a plan he
stayed up late into the night even
though he was very tired from clarinet
practice then when he heard the mutant
creeped into his bedroom he sprang out
of bed in his suit of ultimate power
which yes looked a lot like a pair of
footie pajamas that you have to special
order to fit a boy his size he took out
his mutant vaporizing laser which is
what a laser pointer is if you don't say
pointer and he chased the mutant down
the stairs
the Beast let out a terrified meow which
is what mutants do when they're scared
and recalled from the lasers mighty beam
Johnny strong
chased the mutants out the front door
which he propped open with a rock in a
move that as an adults I admit was
probably unsafe then he shouted Picon
mutant which woke up his baby sister who
started crying
probably tears of joy and hearing that
justice had been served now is Johnny
strong finally celebrated as the hero he
is does the monster ever return we'll
find out in issue 2 which is called land
of the lost cats posters now that is it
for now loss last week tonight return to
September 25th until then Hollywood I am
awaiting your call strongly